-Margot, you're very, very nice.
What did you -- What did you bring me tonight?
-This is an Australian delicacy called fairy bread
typically served at young children's birthday parties
where I'm from.
And since it's your birthday, Jimmy...
-Yeah, it is my birthday. Yeah, of course.
[ Cheers and applause ] -I mean...
I think we should sing Jimmy "Happy Birthday."
-Oh, my goodness. -100%. Don't you think?
-Alright. -Okay.
♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
-Thank you very much.
-♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
-You're amazing.
-♪ Happy birthday, dear Jimmy ♪
-I appreciate it.
-♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you. Thank you.
That is so thoughtful and nice.
I want to make this about you, not about me tonight.
But I'm going have a bite of the -- What is fairy bread?
-Fairy bread is white bread -- the cheaper the better --
butter, and then sprinkles on top.
-Oh, it's fantastic. -And it's great.
If you haven't tried it, I highly recommend it.
-It's good luck. -Don't even wait
for your birthday. Just have it any time.
-Just have it. Fairy bread. Any time.
New York is kind of a second home for you.
-Yes. -Because --
-It's the first place I lived when I moved to America.
-Really? -Yeah.
-Where did you live in New York? -I was living in Brooklyn.
I was in South Williamsburg,
and then I lived in Bed-Stuy for a little bit.
And then I was in -- close to Union Square.
-No way. -Yeah.
-So when you come home, you're like,
"Oh, yeah, I know this place."
-Yeah, it's so -- I came back, and I was like, "Oh, my God.
I want to live here again. I love it so much."
-Yeah. I read somewhere, one of the most --
things that you were excited about seeing
when you come to the States is red Solo cups.
-Yes. -That's very interesting.
-I have to tell you, as an Australian --
and probably, you know, a lot of, you know,
people from other countries -- you come to America,
and you realize that all the things you've seen in a movie
are actually true.
[ Laughter ] Like, I was astounded.
Like, I was like, "Oh, they really do have the grates
on the sidewalk that, like, blow up steam."
And the cabs are all yellow. -Yeah.
-And, like, people do get mad
when you walk slowly on the sidewalk.
Like, I just -- Everything was so exciting.
And it was just like in the movies.
And the thing I got so excited about
that I had always seen in movies was red Solo cups at parties.
And that, we don't have that in Australia.
I don't know why. I -- And that was so thrilling.
And when I would go back to Australia,
literally my friends were like,
"Can you please bring some red Solo cups?
Because we have a party coming up, and it would be so cool."
-So your luggage is filled with red Solo cups.
-No, I would have, like, half a suitcase of red Solo cups.
I don't know why someone's not just importing them
because it would be -- Yeah, go gangbusters.
-Your pal Ryan Gosling was here.
I know he's in the "Barbie" movie with you.
And, by the way, he said you're hilarious.
And he was telling me. I said, "Oh, we love it."
[ Cheers and applause ]
This movie is going to crush.
-I can't tell you how mortified we were, by the way.
We look like we're, like, laughing, having fun,
but dying on the inside.
-You're like, "Oh, my. Oh." -Dying.
-You look so cool. -I was like, "This is the most
humiliating moment of my life." -Yeah.
Did you realize it was going to go everywhere,
all over the Internet? -No.
I mean, I knew that we had some exteriors
to shoot in L.A.
I knew, okay, once you're doing exteriors,
you're gonna get papped.
There's probably going to be a little crowd of people
who are going to take notice because, you know, the fluoro.
We stand out a little in those outfits.
-You think? Yeah, yeah.
-And so I knew there would be a little bit of attention
and probably some photos would get out there,
but not like it did.
It was, like, mad. -Yeah.
-It was, like, hundreds of people watching.
-He said you were so funny in this
and you're so fun to work with.
-He's so funny in this. -Yeah.
I want to talk about "Amsterdam," though.
-Oh, my gosh. Yes. -Oh, my gosh. David O. Russell.
I mean, you can't get better than that.
-I mean, just try and list
the cast members that are in this film.
-Christian Bale. -There's too many.
-Robert De Niro. -Zoe Saldana, Anya Taylor-joy.
Rami Malek. Matthias Schoenaerts.
-Oh, everybody. -Andrea Riseborough.
John David Washington.
I mean, Mike Myers. Michael Shannon.
-Chris Rock is fantastic in this.
-Could go on forever. There's so many.
-Yeah. How is it working with David O. Russell?
-Oh, my gosh. Every day is like a complete --
No day is the same.
-You told me that he almost doesn't ever want to stop.
-No, he doesn't want to stop. Like, he could go forever.
And same with Christian, who's, you know, the lead in this film.
Christian Bale plays this incredible character
and is also a very, very, you know, incredible actor.
And they're both so dedicated to this film and their craft
that we never actually -- Like, he never called "cut."
David never called cut on this film.
So, technically, we didn't ever really stop.
-You're still filming "Amsterdam."
-We're still going.
-You're still filming, and the movie's out.
-It'll be in theaters October 7th, but we are still --
-But, no, we were there, and it was the last day of shooting,
and it was a scene and Christian was, you know, giving --
saying his dialogue.
And David's there, and he's directing.
Chivo, our incredible cinematographer,
is filming and everyone's in it.
But the permit -- You know, the curfew was up.
You know, you get a permit to shoot somewhere.
-Yeah.
-We were in Pasadena, and the time was up.
-Yeah, of course. -And we were meant to clear out, but we wouldn't.
And the producers are freaking out,
and David's still going and Christian's still acting.
And then, eventually, like, the Pasadena police
literally were, like, in the set with us
all being like, "Stop. You have to stop.
Like, you guys have to stop. Like, please."
-The police wrapped this film.
-The police literally -- And I could see this policewoman
trying to think of --
I could see her head being like, "What is the word
they use in the film business to make everything stop?"
And she was like, "Enough! Like, stop! Everyone, stop!"
And then she was like, "Wrap! Wrap!
You're wrapped! Everyone's wrapped!"
-That's a wrap!
-And, honestly, everyone heard the word "wrap,"
put down the equipment, and started packing up.
-"Respect. Take care." -And I was like,
"Wow. A policewoman from Pasadena
just wrapped this film." It was incredible.
-It's a fascinating movie. -Yeah.
-And based on a true story.
-So, based on a lot of true things that happened.
There's a big --
There's a lot of unknown history that is quite astounding
that David and Christian explored a lot, and you see --
You find out a lot of it in the movie,
but really it's a big --
It's, like, an epic comedic thriller.
It's these three -- You follow these three friends
who kind of get caught up
in this murder-mystery conspiracy
and a larger conspiracy, but it's really about, you know,
love and friendship and loyalty. It's very funny.
-It's a good story. It's very funny, very -- Yeah.
And, like you said, you can't name a better --
All this cast. -Yeah.
-Oh, my gosh. -The cast is incredible.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Margot Robbie in "Amsterdam."
Take a look at this.
-I never expected two decorated soldiers
to get knocked out in my own home.
-No. Just one, sir.
-Oh, that's right, Mr. Woodman. You were too fast for Carlton.
-I was.
-They started talking to Valerie, and she's not well.
And please, darling girl, stop crying.
-It's only natural for her to cry.
She just found out her friend is dead.
We couldn't keep it from her for forever.
-I'm not so ill that I can't talk to people.
-You leave me here with this invalid when you know very well
that I think she should be hospitalized.
It's for her own good.
-Don't you ever say that to me again.
-I can't handle -- -I'll put you in a hospital!
I'll send you to a witch trial!
-Please! Please! Ladies! Stop.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry I had to raise my voice.
-Yeah. Margot Robbie, everybody.
"Amsterdam" hits theaters October 7th.